hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
today is gonna be a pretty laid back and
short video just as was the stream today
we got a couple little things to talk
about some small things happening of
course today with for honor and then one
with a collab where if you were
following the twitter of 400 you would
already know what this is about as this
was released a couple days ago
so we're going to be talking about both
things in today's video so as always
like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new i cover the
informational side of 400 that being the
balance changes the hero updates the
patriots and the leaks
if it will be kept up today with
everything happening than the world of
runner and never miss out on an update
definitely stay subscribed to the
channel
and with that let's get started with
today's video so first up there's going
to be a collab with for honor and it's a
collab with samurai
showdown and we are technically getting
anything in trade usually sometimes with
collabs
one game gets one thing the other game
gets another thing
this is more just us putting one of our
characters in samurai
showdown that being warden he's
available in four different colors which
is blue purple red
and yellow and you could pick this game
up whenever you want of course i'm not
sure what the price is
and onward platforms it is but it is
available right now of course the game
is i think it's been out for months
so you could definitely look it up and
if it looks interesting definitely give
it a try
i'll show some of the gameplay that
warden has on screen
he has some very similar moves than what
he has in for honor as well like
shoulder bashes parries and faints
so you can do a lot of those i've never
personally played samurai showdown so i
can't give my own critiques of it but
from the gameplay that they showed
it does look like a very entertaining
fighting game that does definitely have
a skill curve
to some degree just like all fighting
games do and then the last thing for the
video is that the chapter two of metal
trials is
out which means instead of the notable
characters from the campaign it's only
the bosses this time around so it's
going to be just a little bit tougher
and it will go until july 2nd which is
of course the end
of the whole event so we have one more
week with the glorious tester medal
before we have to say goodbye again
so make sure to get all the rewards that
you have all the emotes
the battle outfits the weapons all that
good stuff
and yeah that's pretty much the main
gist of the video that was really all
they really did on stream but i
understand we're still kind of in the
middle
of an event so there's really not much
to talk about especially because the
chapter two isn't like a change of game
mode or anything it's pretty much the
same thing we're just playing with
different characters and
as characters that we've already played
against they're not just grouped up in a
different way
that we get to fight them and yeah
that's pretty much it guys i just wanted
to let you guys know for this
weekly update as always like the view if
you do enjoy subscribe if you're new
i cover the informational slide of for
honor with that guys take care have a
great yesterday
peace out goodbye
[Music]
you